oh boy here you go Alex turns out 90-day
fiance star Alex bro varnak is a
real-life hero he's out look at him he's
knocked the cow man on Sunday Alex's
wife fellow 90 day star Lauren shared
this video on Instagram that's Alex
rescuing what appears to be an
intoxicated man from drowning in the
Bahamas in the video Alex keeps a man's
head above water and eventually lays him
down on the sand to check his breathing
that's when someone off-camera slams the
passed-out man's friends for not helping
him
and his friends are just watching this
lauren is currently pregnant with the
couple's first child together and penned
a lengthy caption alongside the clip
writing in part quote we are meant to be
in a place in time for a reason my
husband saved a man's life today and I
couldn't be more proud yet not surprised
at the same time Lauren also criticized
the man's friends saying that none of
them jumped in to help and they didn't
even ride with him in the ambulance
quote it goes to show you may think your
friends are your friends but God forbid
something bad happens would they help
you or just stand there and watch you
fall always trust your instincts Alex
also shared the video writing that he
was glad he was at the right place at
the right time and was able to help
before it was too late it's been about a
week since Lexi's arrived and what I
thought was the hardest part was getting
him here but now that he's here we've
got a lot to do and we've got to hit
that ground running Alex and Lauren
first starred in season 3 of the hit TLC
reality series which documented Alex
coming to the u.s. to be with Lauren
after they met in Israel it's the day of
our Israeli wedding and we still need to
take some photos with my family and his
family before the guests arrive the
lovebirds are one of the success stories
of the franchise and they celebrated
four years of marriage in September
everything is so unorganized and so well
I got
listen to me from the get-go now the fan
faves weigh in on the other couple
stories on 90 day fiancé pillow top oh
this expensive one know that this is
France well that's it for today of
course you can count on ET to bring you
all the latest on 90 day fiancé so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens and I'll
see you soon
[Music]